I Dunno.
Halloween is just like a weird holiday to be dressing up as anybody else's
culture.
Say the same thing about any costume.
Are you going to tell a six year old girl that she can't dress up like a pirate
because she doesn't know the history of pirates.
Like oh that's very dense.
Three,
we're all technically white.
Yeah,
you're from England,
from Australia.
If you're from wherever,
South Africa,
you know,
we all have these crazy places we come from and these people were around and we
get those ideas from those people.
But that doesn't mean us as a whole have no culture.
And as a white person,
it's not really a culture.
You can have culture like I'm Hella Irish obviously,
and that's a culture.
But then just being white is not a,
it's not a culture.
I can't relate to you just because you're white.
I think you can say that for any ethnicity though,
if we were all black,
can I relate to you guys if just because of the color of our skin?
Yes,
because they go through very similar experiences.
Like they'll get discriminated against and you're not getting discriminated
against because of your skin color.
They can both relate to that,
but I also feel like with culture we branch out.
We tried different things.
We want to do different things.
So maybe we've lost a little bit of our culture.
Maybe we're creating a new culture.
There you go.
Three,
two,
one.
I Dunno what that is.
You can explain it.
Okay.
I'll stay here till like where I just reverse racism is like someone being
racist against you because you are white.
Like do you believe that someone can be racist against a white person?
Yeah.
I grew up where it was completely like Hispanic culture.
I was constantly made fun of because I was white.
Oh,
white people can't dance.
White people look stupid,
whatever.
They shouldn't say white people can't dance,
but they can't.
They
just putting that out there.
But I mean like being honest though,
like they would say those mean things to me and more hurtful things in that it's
like a hard pill to swallow because if I turned around and said black people
can't dance,
I'd get hell for that.
But then if someone says the same words to me,
it's somehow okay because you have to look at the difference of it though.
And I relate to you.
I grew up with all Latino or black friends.
I had very few white friends and yeah,
I got made fun of for being like the white girl I was green got,
and I didn't take offense to it because the huge part about racism is that
there's hate and oppression behind it.
And as a white person in America,
I do not feel oppressed.
And I definitely think that we should take the log out of our own eyes before
worrying about the saw dust and other people's like,
I totally agree with that.
But there is Sada.
So that's kind of what,
just what I'm saying,
for me,
I feel like anything we do can come out racist to any other types of race.
But at the same time if they say something mean or racist to us that we feel is
racist,
it's kind of gets brushed off.
I might think of the word racism.
I think more towards oppression.
So that's why I'm in the disagree.
Like I'll deal with someone just being mean to me.
But whatever,
three,
two,
one.
I think it's important to focus on race in order to bring us together.
There is a race issue in America and if we just avoid it all together and
pretend like it's not happening,
nothing's going to change in my opinion.
I kinda was thinking about the question differently because it's all I'm
thinking about when I meet someone as,
oh,
I'm white and she's not white and I'm white and she's not white like that.
For me that's like what?
Focusing on races.
Yeah.
I'm never going to be happy unless we just like all work together just to like
treat each other like each other.
You know,
like there is no race.
Yeah.
And that,
that sounds great,
but it's like we're not there.
We're not there.
I feel like people who've had that perspective might also say like,
oh,
I don't see color.
Try not,
you know,
try to have that attitude.
I don't think that helps anybody.
I think we need to like the respect each other's backgrounds and like that is
only gonna happen if we do see color we do like appreciate everybody's
differences.
Three,
two,
one.
Yeah.
I think cultural appropriations very real.
You see all the time like Coachella,
you know,
we're in La and you see people and the native American headdresses without
knowing how important that is to native people.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think there's a difference between respecting the culture and completely
disrespecting the culture,
but then also if you want to dress up on Halloween,
like a Geisha because you like the costume,
you think it's a beautiful costume.
That I wouldn't say is,
I wouldn't do that.
I think if you're going to go and dress up as a geisha without knowing the
importance of it and just being like,
well,
this is cute,
like I'm going to put this on.
And also even if you did know the importance and you're like,
I dunno,
Halloween is just like a weird holiday to be dressing up as anybody else's
culture.
Say the same thing about any costume.
Are you going to tell a six year old girl that she can't dress up like a pirate
because she doesn't know the history of pirates?
Like,
oh,
that's a very different,
it's just like that's very different.
Those are,
those are children.
I think it's a lot about intention because I think we're in that thing at
Coachella.
Like I feel like I would see that as that person mocking someone who,
even if they don't intentionally mean it,
it's still a factor.
One
only reason I'm at somewhat disagree is because a lot of my favorite rappers use
it frequently.
Like if I'm listening to my favorite childish Gambino Song,
what's your drops it like a hundred times.
Yeah,
no,
that's a car.
It's like,
it's like I'm not sitting there thinking all these horrible things about black
people and I'm like,
it's just in the song and when I'm singing it comes out,
there's like two different forms of the word.
They're ends with an er and with an a and like with my friends,
they're like,
oh you can say it with an a like that won't hurt my feelings.
Those people told me,
but also like even when I'm in the car by myself,
like I still feel like it's not my place.
Maybe I'll like whisper it like with an a at the end,
you know?
Like if I'm by myself,
but like out of the respect for other people,
I just think it's more appropriate.
And not to say it at all.
Do you guys think rappers should stop putting it in their songs?
I feel like if there,
it's wrong though,
I don't think it's wrong because the history of the n word com,
you know slave owners would call black people as the n word with the hard r at
the end.
If black people want to take that word and claim it as their own and claim that
that painful history and like be like f you,
like I'm going to claim this word.
I think they should be allowed to do that.
I don't think as a white person I have that right to take a word that was
derogatory towards them.
They show 100% have the right to do that.
Okay.
Do you think it's okay for a white person to sing the song to the same?
They're all on the fence.
Like I feel like it's,
it's just,
it's a word used as like,
uh,
my friend basically.
And it like,
just like she said,
if they want to take that back from its horrible origins,
then I'm totally fine with that.
But as,
as a white person,
you can't say that word without,
uh,
feeling a certain way.
Yes.
If you,
if they didn't put it in their songs,
you wouldn't say it,
right?
No.
Yeah.
So are they causing people to say that word more often?
Because she wouldn't say it
white people's place to tell them what they can and cannot use.
So,
ah,
three,
two,
one.
It's so sad to say because I never say it out loud,
but it's,
the truth is like getting pulled over by the police.
I always feel like I have a little bit of a one up because I'm white because I'm
a woman and I feel so bad that that's the truth.
But this is a real thing and it's unfortunate for me as an individual,
I feel like I'm not privileged.
Sure.
Like white people background came from like being higher up on the scale,
but I've gone through really hard things before if you know,
I don't feel like I'm superior over other people.
So as an individual I don't feel like I'm,
I think privileged,
I guess.
I don't really think that I'm above other people.
I just think that naturally I'm treated differently.
It's just perception.
Yeah,
I think that's a huge misconception.
I have privileged that I didn't ask for it.
It's just society sees me as like the standard for whatever reason.
And because of that I get treated differently and I'm white privilege.
You know?
Like you said,
it's not about what you've gone through or what you experienced.
It's 100% how the world sees me.
Do
can there be,
alright.
Don't worry guys.
I almost went there too.
Right.
I think like guilt.
Like I am like happy that I'm not oppressed but I'm not proud of like things
people have done in the past.
When I,
when I think of big proud or something I think of something I worked for or that
um,
I yeah,
I had to get,
I had to do nothing to be white,
absolutely nothing and nothing was taken from me because I was white.
It's like saying
I'm a proud white person is a completely different saying than saying I'm a
proud black person because when you hear I'm a proud black person,
I think empowerment.
I think strength.
I think courage.
I think,
you know,
all these amazing things that the black community has done and accomplished
throughout the years.
But then when you say I am a straw or I'm a proud white person already,
there's so much like hate.
Yeah.
Involved in that.
Thinking about that is like,
like how you said,
someone who says,
I'm proud to be black.
That's empowerment.
Why aren't I allowed to be proud to be white?
What makes it,
yeah.
What are you proud of?
Just your skin color because yes,
that is wrong.
So you're saying I can't be proud to be white because I don't have a culture.
No,
that's not what I'm am saying that when white people say that they're proud to
be white,
a lot of times,
at least in my opinion,
they're just,
they're talking about their skin color,
that they're not under a different race.
I think that's wrong.
Yeah.
But um,
as like,
and we were talking about it as a proud black person,
they'd been oppressed that a lot of their culture was stolen from them.
And then a lot of reasons that I don't like,
proud to be white.
It's because it has the,
the Nazis used it,
the KKK used it.
I don't want to be associated with any of those things,
so I'm just going to completely stay away from that.
Sure.
I'm not proud of like what my culture is done,
but at the same time,
like I would not want to be anything else if I had to choose another race.
I don't know what I would be.
I'm okay with where I am even though I'm getting backlash about being white.
I was waiting on the food question.
Do you like Starbucks?
Hey guys,
this is John and I'm Erin.
Thank you so much for watching this episode of spectrum.
We hope you enjoyed the discussion.
Let us know what you thought in the comments below and if you'd like to watch
more videos,
click here to subscribe and we'll see you next time.